all right hey everyone Dogan here so
everyone knows that Japanese convenience
stores are incredible amazing awesome so
I wanted to take this opportunity to
show you guys what I got at my Japanese
convenience store haul earlier today
let's get into it Chris this is the
first thing Band-Aids I cut my finger
earlier today I was uh trying to cut
some carrots there we go and I just
think that it's amazing that you can get
something you know to fix yourself up at
a moment's notice in Japan I mean it's
great it's one of the reasons I love
Japan I got one of these uh egg
sandwiches Japanese people have these
all the time I've never actually had one
of these egg sandwiches before let's try
it out
foreign
oh my God
oh my God that is so good man Japan
coming through in the clutch this is why
I really love Japan not only is this
like amazing and it was like a dollar
which is crazy but on top of that I mean
like Japan is known for being extremely
healthy I'm sure if I have this you know
like every day maybe even like two
that's gonna be way better than the
alternative back home which was like
oatmeal and blueberries or whatever so
love Japan not worried about you know
any potential Health ramifications right
no it's um sorry someone was cheap it
says
roasted green tea oh man that smells so
good
hmm
guys got like that Japanese like um
Aroma even if there are any like
potential downsides to those Foods I was
eating earlier I'm sure there aren't but
even if there were you know like this
roasted green tea this is like drinking
like medicines there's been some studies
that show that like it'll bring your age
back by like 10 or 15 years I think is
what it said I mean and it makes sense
because it's
wow okay um the design of this like
bottle I mean it's so like you know
refined and like
Scott like this playful character to it
it's so much different from like you
know the stuff back you know Coca-Cola
it's like come on man like you know try
a little bit harder get learn from
um Ito end do you really feel like the
craftsmanship that they put into this
course the next item is
um these socks which I also got from the
convenience store is it you know like a
place where you get like magazines and
like maybe a couple snacks or is it like
a full-on apparel shop The Best of Both
Worlds I can't read all these kanji but
let me open it up and see how these feel
oh it's got like the stretch action
going on oh I love that I love that I'm
gonna put these on oh yeah oh yeah those
those feel good but that oh man I bet
it's like some Japanese like traditional
like um sewing technique I cannot go
back to the States like I'm so used to
all this incredible stuff socks
Band-Aids come on I also got one of
these
um protein in protein packs a special
jelly drink designed to supply protein
as more easily absorbed peptides for
supporting your daily exercise to
improve your physical condition not
sure 100 what all of that means I love
the action pack
foreign
this like like a health product can
taste as good man I wish I could read
these cons in Japan love Japan okay so
this I'm really excited for I got some
um bum kuhen uh I've actually got some
German blood I don't think that most of
the viewers know this but as someone
with German blood I'm kind of like an
authority on this kind of thing oh man
this smell they nailed the smell this is
like so so much like the real thing back
in the States here we go
oh my God okay I need to like take a
moment here this is better than the real
thing I can't believe I'm saying this
but oh my God everything I've tried
today too you know it's like the
Band-Aid just works the socks super
comfortable the protein pack I mean if
I'd had that in high school when I was
doing martial arts I probably could have
easily gotten like you know like a black
belt three months earlier all right so
I've got a couple more food items let's
check these out peanut butter sandwich
but it's crazy because it's like you
can't even well I'll just show you guys
I'm not sure how to describe this but
the bread has no crust
um
okay okay it's like clearly a a Japanese
peanut we're gonna I can't read
I can't read all the kanji but I love
how like I don't have to worry about
like I don't have to feel guilty for
eating this because you know Japan again
is known for being such a healthy
country I see Japanese people eating
these and they live forever this I'm not
worried right now whether or not you
know my my blood sugar levels are
spiking I love Japan I feel like I could
eat like 10 of these and just still keep
going I saw this and I just thought this
was like so cool you know just like a
little little tiny notepad there are so
many times when it's like I have like a
great thought and I'm like I want to
write that down but then I don't have
anything on me so it's it's great that I
can you know go to a convenience store
which is again super close and pick one
of these up and then it's like okay got
an idea let's pull it out boom Oh man
and that is so easy to ride on what
should I write um
I love Japan I
don't
love Dad I love like this kind of you
know super like Zen minimalist aesthetic
this is what I love about Japan like
people actually still write things it's
so cool I miss that really all right so
that's the video um again like I I'm
just like blown away that you can get
all this incredible stuff at any
convenience store in Japan got the
Bandit I don't have to worry about
whether I'm gonna get hurt it's like
having like a mini Hospital anywhere I
go bam kuhan like again better than the
real thing how much more praise can I
give Japan is there anything beyond
perfect these socks these socks I feel
like I'm riding the Nimbus like wearing
these socks every time I go to the
convenience store and do like a haul
like this it reinforces my love for the
country my love for the people I mean
the person at the register today I think
she was actually from Nepal the point
still stands look at these colors that's
what I love about Japan you can feel
like the culture and everything and the
egg sandwich and the bomb Cool Hand all
right but I gotta end the video here all
right like if I get started I can
I feel like I'm getting like emotional
like this is how I I get when I talk
about Japan how did I spend 20 years of
my life in this United States you know
it's like
everything back there is so stupid so
backwards like I hated everything
in the United States like there's
nothing good about the United States
it's just stupid I I don't like it um
and I don't want to go back I really
love Japan so much more so I'm just
happy to be here um how about this can
we do a big thumbs up for Japan thumbs
if you thumbs up if you love Japan give
me a thumbs and then a sub as well and
we can do this again soon we'll go to
like a Japanese uh grocery store maybe
like a Japanese like um
we'll figure something out I'm in Japan
right yeah okay so I'm gonna end the
video here hopefully you guys enjoyed it
and see you again soon all right later
oh I feel like [ __ ]
oh God
easy money
hmm
oh oh shoot okay love Japan love Japan